the countdown is on there are just 11
shopping days before Christmas and if
you want those gifts to get where you
want them to go and I know you do
they're running out of time to order
online the first big holiday shipping
deadline is today Chris Vancleave is at
a FedEx sorting Center just outside
Memphis where lots of packages are being
prepared for delivery Chris good morning
I know it's hectic there
well good morning it is time to get
serious about your shipping this is the
deadline for FedEx ground this sorting
Center will handle about 10 000 packages
just today this is the last stop before
they get delivered and if your gifts
aren't in some of these boxes you need
to start thinking about how they're
going to get where you want them to go
that is the sound of the holidays plane
after plane touching down at the FedEx
Mega Hub in Memphis each carrying around
20 000 packages there's not a lot of
slow that happens here
not a lot of lingering
we're on the tarmac with senior
operations manager Walter kirkemind we
understand that some of these gifts are
highly personal and really the brand is
on the line
over the course of the day about 2.4
million packages pass through here a
gift size Amazing Race Against The Clock
they're sorted via 44 miles of conveyor
belts before being loaded onto another
set of planes Bound for their final
destinations
all in about three hours for the excess
capacity that Santa doesn't have on the
sleigh we're helping drop it off with
our purple-tailed airplanes
relocate to gate 124 is approved
advisory in the gate overnight the
Memphis Airport turns into one of the
busiest airfields in the world about 250
flights come and go every 24 hours right
now it looks like we have about 10 in
range from this FedEx airport tower
Maria bonds has to find a place to park
all those planes we make sure that these
aircraft go where they need to go in a
timely manner and we are the Santa with
the purple tail if you're a Santa with a
purple toe what is that what does that
make you and an elf an elf an elf this
Command Center is a bit like NORAD for
packages tracking all the FedEx flights
we're looking at the weather every 10
minutes to figure out if it's something
we need to deviate our planes 538 that's
me that's you but there's no deviating
drivers like Jacob Tucker Before Sunrise
packages are loaded into delivery Vans
headed for you just like Santa's Little
Helper I feel like I'm able to give to
the customer before the holiday season
all right so FedEx Ground deadline is
today First Class Postal Service mail
deadline Saturday Monday is the prior
priority mail deadline after that if I
want to get these purple hats to you
guys in New York I'm gonna have to send
them overnight and that gets pretty
expensive Nate
well you can afford it it does look good
on you though and we were just talking
about I love that guy could you
transition could you send a few of them
here to New York please
appreciate you Chris have a good one all
right we're serious Chris
that's not TV banter I would like a
purple hat